welcome to this video playing group he's
not from Spain if this is semenax Stein
actor Stein well known no vegan rent
master maybe it's playing some
tournament and in Spain at the moment
this is why the Spanish like it's on now
but it's not playing a shame good to
have a one on grand master as an
opponent yeah sometimes they they press
the button but they um the the you play
press the button to play a five minute
game and then you're away because you
get a phone call or whatever have to
attend the door and then the game starts
with you being being off I gave him the
time back so that we start fair and
square you can do that you can add time
to your opponent's clock so we have the
decimation tips or damage let's see how
is going to play that now with v6 okay
I think you can go in for him hmm he
allows Bishop g5 okay well let's try
that setting up this somewhat awkward
pin okay just 92 yeah he might be able
to to grab the other see for pong with
95 but that's so common in the Z Misha
it's hard to worry about that so maybe
castling okay here comes to 50 k 9 a-5
I'm going I'm going with F for this I
had an in some earlier game almost the
same thing maybe also here maybe also
here can i still play that f4 it's very
very aggressive Knight takes bishop it
gets to this very very strong pin okay
I'm trying for that it's at least
interesting g takes 90 on airg text i
can even start with bishop h4 and if it
takes it Bishop h 4 sets up this this
dangerous pin
yeah I guess he must take on f4
otherwise I'm going to go 95 and just
have this fantastic attack against his
King position it's it's a fairly
standard way to play here with therefore
and the peace sacrifice it's happened a
lot in in in similar positions at least
not in this particular one but in
similar I guess I wonder does he really
have an alternative to 2g takes a form I
mean good or good or bad at a Musa are
simply simply am NOT not on wow isn't
this night h5 like winning instantly why
isn't this winning instantly okay he's
going to he needs to show me
after takes Queen takes this f7 hanging
air okay and now i have e five at least
five on as there's also Queen g-form and
tending Queen g7 or queen f3 they all
look very strong Queen f3 27 also five
okay I'm going if I p.m.
yeah yeah I can take play Queen d3 and
tending rook takes f7
now that's deadly come on not going to
try to calculate this till the end they
must be winning um takes rook f1 check
King down now okay it's it's winning so
let's let's get ahead and sacrifice um
first this chats probably both winning
that is made I can maybe sacrifice the
Queen somehow check Queen f7 mate next
yeah this is so lack resign the beauty
of this opening sometimes it's very much
right in yeah very very right on very
direct and this this stuff like fo I had
a head earlier and in some game it's
it's very dangerous I think you must
somehow react to that maybe night h5 the
nith five is the is the the calm
suggestion here to to look at look at
their foursquare maybe this is the right
move how to evaluate this is very
complicated position compass on on about
equal him but after this i think a force
is interesting oh yeah the computer now
gives also a form i had almost the same
position in an earlier game it was the
same motive at least and here it gets
very very difficult from like the
computer wants to play Knight h5 and
gives white 0.7 yeah nie Dage 5 is not a
move that you had your happy to play but
here it's interesting that the comp it
wants to play root gap form i wanted to
go here ok that's also winning plus 3
the pin is absolutely deadly he also
does not really have this move if we
look here this d5 also in the in the
game you know he will be losing on this
pin those two pieces are just spectators
now this is this is very strong i think
ruler but look fo i didn't really
appreciate and because here yeah this is
also very strong this is a tech it's
also plus 4
okay it's easy for the comp but I
thought this is just giving me the
attack with with Noah no problems
whatsoever d 5 is also the best move
according to the comp okay yeah auntie
em I think that this should be quite
convincing yeah we have seven this check
yeah nice i almost one hundred percent
match mature stock fish or or whatever
engine you might look at it it looks
really good but it's had this on the
board earlier so f was not a move that
needs so much consideration it's pretty
clear that it's working here but he must
play play night age 5 to prevent it okay
thanks for watching